welcome to microsoft summit 2020 uh good
morning afternoon evening i'm bolivian
from microsoft i'm going to present my
work topics of learning into the
dialogue it's a joint work with my
manager jimin got from microsoft
research and professor halimang from the
chain disease research on hong kong uh
here's the agenda of a birthday
introduced the background on passport
followed by our motivation of
self-learning and the proposal of
leading taskbot then talk about
experiment to validate the proposal
framework finally include the talk
this is a classical data system
architecture language standing component
identifying user intent dialog manager
track user go make decision on how to
respond then generation model converts
my labels on to natural language
with recent velocity in europe approach
to consumer ai
the most common approach of building
taskbar is to train your model to
immediate behavior in in the larger
scale limited labor dialogue
but libertarian
protruding are fine-tuned in
paradigmatic largely protonated model uh
has a limited data smart scarity problem
to large scent and become increasingly
prevalent for building transport skill
let's briefly summarize the pros and
cons of each method conventional
synchronous learning is straightforward
is easy to implement but labor decent
labor intensive and prohibitively
expensive to collect and empty light
coppers for training and fine tuning
substantially reduce the required number
entity to training example but the trend
data limit has limited coverage dialog
flows
more importantly this digital approach
assumes
independent identical distribution in
data setting it is the aesthetic
environment it tends to feel when
confirming other distribution examples
it is a change environment changing run
is pretty common in the concept context
dialog system because of usability there
is a lot of more relative language
policy in real world than presenting
trend data and the second is the data
definition is the system needed to
handle new software as user and business
requirement involved
uh here is an internal example after
default deployment the system failed to
provide postal code in the second turn
due to usability is in their turn the
agency responds with the postal code the
interaction i abandoned to chip and
content contains painful potential
training signals
we
argue that taskbar should not merely
emit the extra behavior in a corporate
but also learn from this human body and
actions accumulated after deployment to
adapt to changing environment so in this
work we propose a no whatsapp learning
framework for building task body a more
realistic changing environment setting
allows what to adapt to twin dramas by
learning from the human body in action
after deployment
uh it consists of two uh component
dialogue model uh it can be whatever
intuitive model for psd tracking and
responsion the second is one model
spread trend language uh transform model
adjusts the quality response
uh it already in four-step the first
first day for finally with limited labor
data and then we deployed the model to
users and accumulate interaction
and then refine the data model with the
human interactions via reinforcement the
budget allow the recruit annotator to
correct out logs via machine teaching
the dollar model is self-learning agent
is compatible with any internet data
model in this product we employ solist
as the dollar model resulting in agent
called self learning soloist
we briefly recap service model it takes
dollar history as input and general glib
state which they use to query database
the results that will be part of the
input to the model to generate final
response it is portrayed on public label
task granted dialog and can be used for
quick adaptation to new tasks
the reward will adjust the quality in
terms of fluency success data flow
consistency we form a task as a binary
classification problem
it innate from protein transformer to
predict the quality given the context
of the integrated authority types
generate the training separations
we automatically crack the training
example to obtain positive and negative
trained data
machine teaching is an effective way to
add new knowledge to update the system
especially when we need to handle task
definition changes
in our
implementation we use consistent lender
to visualize the dialogue and crack the
bleep state to add new responses
we conduct current on four-wheel study
dialogue
tasks attraction training hotel and
restaurant we divide the university into
two parts setting one to simulate the
user behavior changes the set setting to
task definition changes we finally
present interactive communications
the eurasian metro includes inform
success blue and the combined score
inform trend indicate if the ball checks
correctly entity that match user goal
the success matters if the bot answers
all request information blue skull
matters
if the responses are fluent and
accumulated the combined score is a
witness some other overall matrix
we are deploying a trinidad to integrate
the real measure uh to collect the
intentional labor intensive so we create
a similar setting by adding noise into a
rendered dataset to simulate a community
interaction ten percent of the data will
be used at
for training ninety percent crop data is
noisy interaction uh here is the result
we see that self learning solid
performed significantly better than
solaced uh showing that our framework
enables learning from unlabeled
interaction but still lag behind the
upper bound results showing there is
still a large room for improvement
especially improve the quality
of this reward model
similar setting allows effortlessly
experimental studies to wear the profit
the effectiveness of proposed method
however the results are likely based
therefore we can document the loop
evaluation we deploy the trade model to
integrate the real user and collect
interactions we collect additional 10
percent real human body interactions
uh here's the result we see that uh
learning from real
human body dialogues further brings
three point improvements we confirmed
that simulation relation and human
looking us results are consistent which
means that self-learning agent enables
both to learn from interaction to adapt
to user behavior changes
for the second
setting task definitions we extend the
restaurant with additional slot to serve
food delivery by adding four new slots
resulting the domain restaurant
extension ten examples obtained via
machine teaching for training 20
real user dialogue for self learning and
50 example for testing
we see that machine teaching is an
effective way to teach about our task
definition is
a learning from interactions brings
seven points improvement inhabiting the
effectiveness of self-learning agent to
adapt to change environment caused by
task definition dates
we also conduct human evaluation using
the same protocol as we used last year
when we organized the uh dialogue
challenge
we recruit real quick my user to chat
with our system and the rate user
performance
uh we see that the
results are consistent as the automatic
relation demonstrate the capabilities of
learning agent for complete completing
tasks in real scenarios
so to conclude this talk we propose
and focus on more realistic changing
environment setting for building taskbot
we propose self-learning agent which is
a self-learning framework that combines
the surprise learning
reinforcement and machine teaching for
building taskbar in a more realistic
changing environment setting experiments
on four will study the differential that
cellular agent allowed us to adapt to
changing garments by learning from the
human body in action after deployment
as to the field work there are more ways
that a taskbar could learn to improve
itself for example human expert could
provide not only the crowd label but
also the feedback english language so we
leave learning from niche language from
human being as future work thanks